你有没有想过股票当充真的可以做到胜率超高
我不是在开玩笑
我自己就已经做到了
而且你知道吗
多数人之所以做不到
并不是技术不好
而是认知完全卡关
最神奇的是我见过太多有技术的老手
只要我把他们那个错误的旧观念一扳证
他们就像打通认读二脉一样
马上脱胎换股
从损意起伏不定变成稳定活力
大家好我是莫卡
已经有8年的实战当充经验
指导过3000多名学员
今天我就来颠覆一个
你最根深蒂固的观念
你是不是也觉得要赚钱
就一定要追求高胜率
觉得只要找到一个省准的方法
没买臂涨就能财富自由
错了
这根本是天达的误会
来我们做个小实验
假设你有一个方法
胜率高达90%
每做10次交易就有9次赚钱
一次赔钱
听起来超强对吧
但如果你赚的时候只赚1000块
赔的时候却一次赔掉1万块
你算算看
做了10次
你赚了9000
赔了1万
结果还倒退1000
這種高勝率到底有什麼用
這就是你必須知道的另一個關鍵
風險報酬比
你賺錢時賺多少
賠錢時賠多少
這個比例才是重點
所以我們應該追求高勝率
還是追求好的風險報酬比
這個問題本身又錯了
因為這兩個都不是最終答案
那什麼才是答案
我認為是期望值
白話文就是你平均每交易一次
能賺多少錢
這才是決定你會不會賺錢的終極答案
期望值怎麼算
簡單的公式是
平均赚钱金额乘上胜率
减掉平均赔钱金额乘上败率
这个公式算出来的数字
只要是正数
长期下来你就一定会赚钱
是负数
你计数再生
玩久了也是输狗
但这里有一个最重要的关键
样本数
你只做10次交易
就算你的期望值是正的
也可能因为运气不好而赔钱
但如果你交易了100次1000次你的获利就会无限接近于你计算出来的期望值这才是真正的穩定獲利接下來我就要來揭秘我是怎麼做到穩定獲利的關鍵就在於你的計算單位
如果你跟一般人一樣要求每一筆交易都賺錢
那我可以明白告訴你
不可能沒有人能做到
但是如果你把週期拉長
把一個月當作一個單位來計算勝率呢
那我告訴你
你就能做到每個月都獲利
一個月22個交易日
就算你有7天都賠錢
也沒關係
只要你把期望值顧好
你也能跟我一樣
每個月都穩定獲利
怎麼做到的
答案就是極短線當充
我的方法每一次進出場非常快
迎軍大概5分鐘
快的時候甚至30秒就結束一單
聰明如你
應該看出來了
正因為我做一單的時間極短
我一天就有機會做一次到五次不等
然後我的策略
每一單的勝率大約80%
風險報籌比大約是2比3
也就是賠的時候只賠2塊錢
賺的時候可以賺3塊錢
你幫我算算看
假設我做100次交易
贏80次输20次
总盈利80次乘以3块钱等于赚240元
总归损20次乘以赔2元等于赔40元
总计毛赚200元
后掉手续费和交易税
至少可以赚180元没问题
期望值是妥妥的正值
再加上极短线速度快的优势
每个月我都有足够的样本数
让我的结果趋近于期望值
这就是我每个月都能达到
持续稳定获利的核心秘密
我不是在预测市场
我是在用機率和廣利從市場裡領錢
聽到這裡
你是不是忽然覺得
獲利這條路從一團迷路變得清晰許多了
原來不需要盲目追求神準
而是需要一套聰明的系統
這套完整的極短線當沖交易策略
如果你想親眼看看
從新法學股到競出場
這套方法怎麼運作
現在就到下方資訊欄
點擊連結免費觀看我的試聽課程
我是摩卡
我想用一句話結束今天的分享
交易不是跟市場搏鬥
而是跟自己的無知和解
希望你今天又多和解了一點
我們下次見